- [Voiceover] Before we
go in-depth on meiosis,
I want to do a very high level overview
comparing mitosis to meiosis.
So, in mitosis, this is all a review,
if you've watched the mitosis video,
in mitosis, we start with a cell,
that has a diploid number of chromosomes.
I'll just write 2n to show
it has a diploid number.
For human beings, this
would be 46 chromosomes.
46 for humans, you get 23
chromosomes from your mother,
23 chromosomes from your
father or you can say
you have 23 homologous pairs,
which leads to 46 chromosomes.
Now after the process of mitosis happens
and you have your
cytokinesis and all the rest,
you end up with two cells that each
have the same genetic
information as the original.
So you now have two cells
that each have the diploid
number of chromosomes.
So, 2n and 2n.
And now each of these cells
are just like this cell was,
it can go through interphase again.
It grows and it can replicate its DNA
and centrosomes and grow some more
then each of these can
go through mitosis again.
And this is actually how
most of the cells in your body grow.
This is how you turn from a
single cell organism into you,
or for the most part, into you.
So that is mitosis.
It's a cycle.
After each of these
things go through mitosis,
they can then go through
the entire cell cycle again.
Let me write this a little bit neater.
Mitosis, that s was a
little bit hard to read.
Now what happens in meiosis?
What happens in meiosis?
I'll do that over here.
In meiosis, something
slightly different happens
and it happens in two phases.
You will start with a cell
that has a diploid number of chromosomes.
So you will start with a cell
And in it's interphase, it
also replicates its DNA.
And then it goes through
something called Meiosis One.
And in Meiosis One,
what you end up with is two cells
that now have haploid
number of chromosomes.
So you end up with two cells,
You now have two cells that each have a
haploid number of chromosomes.
So you have n and you have n.
So if we're talking about human beings,
you have 46 chromosomes here,
and now you have 23
chromosomes in this nucleus.
And now you have 23 in this nucleus.
But you're still not done.
Then each of these will
go through a phase,
which I'll talk about
in a second, which is
very similar to mitosis, which will
duplicate this entire cell into two.
So actually, let me do it like this.
So now, this one,
you're going to have four cells
that each have the haploid number
that each have the haploid
number of chromosomes.
And they don't all
necessarily have the same
genetic informatioin anymore.
Because as we go through this first phase,
right over here of meiosis,
and this first phase
here you go from diploid to
haploid, right over here,
this is called Meiosis One.
Meiosis One,
you're essentially splitting
the homologous pairs
and so this one might get some of the
ones that you originally
got from your father,
and some that you originally
got from your mother,
some that you originally
got from your father,
got from your mother,
they split randomly,
but each homogolous pair
gets split up.
And then in this phase, Meiosis Two,
so this phase right over
here is called Meiosis Two,
it's very similar
to mitosis, except your now
dealing with cells that start off
with the haploid number.
It's important to realize
that meiosis is not a cycle.
These cells that you have
over here, these are gametes.
This are sex cells.
These are gametes.
This can now be used in fertilization.
If we're talking about, if
you're male, this is happening
in your testes, and these
are going to be sperm cells
If you are female, this is
happening in your ovaries
and these are going to be egg cells.
If you a tree, this could be
pollen or it could be an ovul.
But these are used for fertilization.
These will fuse together
in sexual reproduction
to get to a fertilized
egg, which then can undergo
mitosis to create an
entirely new organism.
So not a cycle here,
although these will find sex cells
from another organism and fuse with them
and those can turn into another organism.
And I guess the whole
circle of life starts again.
But it's not the case with
mitosis where this can keep
going and going, going.
This cell is just like this
cell, while these sex cells
are differeent than this
one right over here.
Now, where does this happen in the body?
We've talked about this
in previous videos.
These are your somatic
cells right over here.
These are the ones that make
up the bulk of your body,
somatic cells.
And where is this happening?
Well, this is happening in germ cells,
As we mentioned, if you're
male it's in your tesis
and if you're female it's in your ovaries.
And germ cells actually
can undergo mitosis
to produce other germ
cells that have a diploid
number of chromosomes, or they can undergo
meiosis in order to
produce sperm or egg cells
in order to produce gametes.